well president Trump's fellow
Republicans are scrambling to contain
the damage from his remarks and health
sinking Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell joined the demand for a
stronger message about election meddling
I think the Russians need to know that
there are a lot of us who fully
understand what happened in 2016 and it
really better not happen again
in 2018 Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
where other lawmakers won't accept the
president's efforts to correct himself
Nancy good morning good morning well
Republican leaders are relieved that the
president at least appears to have
accepted the political reality that his
stance was alienating the intelligence
community and a good part of his own
party but they still worry that the
damage here at home and abroad cannot
fully be undone and they want more power
for Congress to be able to sanction
Russia itself I think he realizes he
made a mistake
Republicans welcomed the president's
course corrections what I wish he would
have said initially but Democrats were
skeptical it would stick I give these
comments about 24 hours before he once
again slams the investigation both sides
still have a lot of questions about that
two-hour meeting with Putin bottom line
is I want to know more about what went
on between President Trump and President
Putin where are the notes from that
meeting the contemporaneous notes what
did the president agree to New Hampshire
Democrat jeanne Shaheen is even calling
on the Senate to hold a hearing with the
u.s. interpreter who was present during
president Trump's meeting with Putin to
uncover what they discussed privately
Republicans meanwhile are rallying
around a bipartisan bill co-authored by
Marco Rubio that would automatically
impose new sanctions if Russia
interferes in another US election Putin
won't have to sit around wondering what
will happen if I do this he will know up
front what will happen Democrats want to
go even further they're pushing for
legislation that would require the
president to publicly reveal his tax
returns and the extent of Russian
investments they say that the fact that
he missed the
and and T in that press conference don't
fully explain why he was so deferential
to President Putin not just in that
press conference but really over the
past several years Nancy thanks you know
that is interesting yesterday's press
event by the president was meant to
clear up this simple question of Russia
and when he said there are a lot of
other people out there that's been the
basis of the questions about whether he
really believes this in the first place
going all the way back to January of
2016 he said I think it could be Russia
or a lot of other people he essentially
has held the same position and continues
to about whether they really were
involved and I think also left on the
table as Nancy mentioned is this
question of whether he's going to hold
Russia to account and also the moral
equivalence that disturbed so many
Republicans that he seemed to show in
that press conference suggesting that
America and Russia were equally to blame
for the state of relations I've been
following Russian media and even they
are confused by the president's actions
owning I would imagine the White House
did not think we'd still be talking
about this three days later after what
they thought would be a really
impressive productive summit and
probably three days more to come as well